North Korea is hacking into our
electricity grid as we speak let me
explain
see Kim Jong-un knows it's hard for him
to compete on the physical Battlefield
with booth on the ground against
countries like America so he decided to
get creative and take his military into
the Cyber Battlefield think about it
imagine what would happen if America
lost power for a day Banks and
businesses were shut down hospitals
wouldn't be able to access medical
records factories would be a standstill
billions of dollars would be lost after
just one day but what if the blackout
lasted for seven days what if it was
even longer
now imagine how hard it would be to take
down America's power grid through
traditional military means bombers
missiles Rockets it would be a
logistical nightmare that would cost a
fortune both thinks North Korea does not
have but how hard would it be to achieve
the same effect through hackers
realistically if the hackers are good
enough you would only need a handful of
them all crammed into an affordable
small building in North Korea that is
why in a surprisingly short amount of
time this special division of North
Korea's military went from practically
nothing to one of the most dangerous
cyber warfare groups on the planets
they're basically on the same level as
the hacker armies of global superpowers
like China and the US and after years of
terrorizing businesses hospitals
stealing billions in crypto they've
earned a nickname The Lazarus group they
even have their own cute logo and their
most recent mission was launching a ton
of attacks against major American energy
companies between February and July of
this year and the public is only just
finding out about this now
how did they pull it off was something
called The Log 4J exploit this exploit
caused major Panic right before
Christmas last year
it gave attackers access to hundreds of
millions if not billions of devices
worldwide cloud storage service hospital
equipment kids video games anything that
connected to a network was fair game and
this wasn't just a bad piece of code you
could just slap a patch on and call it a
day no no no this was so widespread that
it could be coming back to haunt us for
years we're going to be dealing with
this vulnerability amen for a very long
time this is not something that is going
to be patched and finished this is
something that we're going to be working
on likely for months if not years just
given the ubiquity of the software and
the ease of exploitation see in the
world of cyber warfare there are no
rules there are no Geneva conventions
and no target is off limits North
Korea's hackers have proven time and
time again that they mean business
and now North Korea is aiming to bring
our infrastructure to its knees and the
U.S energy grid is way more vulnerable
than we realized
stay dangerous and this is the Lazarus
group
[Music]
and really fast if you want to earn some
free cash then you gotta check out free
cash.com free cash.com lets you earn
free cash by completing simple tasks
like downloading apps playing games
taking surveys watching videos and more
like this task where you literally just
have to download Tick Tock and you'll
earn 88 cents or this one where you just
download and start a free trial of
expressvpn and you'll earn a dollar 45.
there are even offers where you can earn
up to ten to fifty dollars once you
complete the offer you'll get the reward
credited to your accounts and then you
can withdraw your money using 20
different Cash Out options like PayPal
after completing a few offers I was able
to withdraw five dollars to my PayPal
minus a five percent PayPal fee free
cash is over 20 000 positive reviews on
trustpilot and on average free cash
users Cash Out fifty thousand dollars
every single day from completing tests
and if you want to be earning something
about money pause the video and sign up
for free by clicking my referral link
below pause the video and click the link
below now thanks to free cash for
sponsoring this video
foreign what you have to understand is
that the people you see around you in
your day-to-day life right now may look
civilized and peaceful but remember we
are only one meal away from a revolution
that is the power of attacking a
country's electricity grid and while the
U.S may very well be one of the most
developed Nations on Earth America's
electricity grid is very fragile there
are 55 000 key places in America's power
grid called substations links in the
chain that bring electricity from power
plants to homes and businesses if just
nine of these substations in the right
places were taken out all at once the
entire United States would lose power
coast to coast and the first 24 hours of
an attack like this would be miserable
people trapped in elevators would have
to be rescued if they can be reached at
all air traffic control centers wouldn't
function so any flights in the air at
the time would have to fend for
themselves ATMs and bank cards would be
worthless so purchasing anything without
paper money would be impossible backup
generators at hospitals supermarkets and
water treatment plants would run out
after a day or two and without
electricity it would be impossible to
refill at gas station pumps so cars and
generators would quickly become useless
too all refrigerated food would
eventually spoil cities would eventually
run out of drinking water and with no
pumps running in sewage systems all
indoor plumbing would fail cell phone
towers would lose backup power cutting
off all chances to make phone calls it
would get real bad fast okay
[Music]
not only that but after the supply chain
shortages and the housing market boom
we've seen over the last couple years
important parts like Transformers are in
such severe shortage that experts are
already calling it a national security
risk if an attack like this were to
happen now we'd be looking at 18 months
before anyone could turn the lights back
on How likely is this kind of Doomsday
situation it's hard to say exactly but
the thing is cyber attacks like this
have been attempted before in December
of 2016 Russia hacked into Ukraine's
power grid and used a virus to flip
every single circuit breaker at a power
station just north of Kiev almost the
entire city went dark for hours but what
made this attack truly frightening was
that the virus was programmed to also
turn off the station's protective relays
the plan was to catch Ukrainian
engineers in a trap workers would have
been in such a hurry to turn those
circuit breakers back on that when they
did it would trigger a current overload
destroying key parts of the station with
the station ruined Kiev would have been
without power for weeks even months
until all the repairs could be made the
only reason it didn't work was that for
some reason part of the code was
accidentally sent to the wrong IP
address a tiny little mistake prevented
Kiev from descending Into Darkness but
is North Korea even capable of such an
attack unfortunately they've spent the
last several years proving that the
answer is yes
foreign
[Music]
it seems weird to think that a country
as Tiny as North Korea could be a threat
to the United States they love to scare
people by showing off their nuclear
weapons all the time sure but how many
nukes do they actually have compared to
the US not that many it turns out they
could also try to brag that they have
the fourth largest army in the world see
that us we have almost as many troops
and tanks as you still think we're tiny
except these are ex-soviet tanks that
are so old and run down they should
probably be in a museum and their
soldiers are literally starving to death
their own families have had to step in
to bring them food and troops are even
violently robbing their own citizens
because their malnutrition is so bad out
the fact is North Korea just doesn't
have the funding for an elite military
and international sanctions aren't
changing anytime soon but the Kim
Dynasty knows the importance of an idea
called asymmetric Warfare if you have an
enemy more powerful than you taking them
head on is a bad idea unless you can
find a way to do it where it makes all
their advantages meaningless
and Kim Jong-il knew that the internet
would give them just that Advantage as
Kim Jong-il wisely said quote modern war
is decided by one's conduct of
electronic warfare end quote and that
quote if the internet is like a gun
cyber attacks are like atomic bombs end
quote so when Kim Jong-un took over in
2012 he carried on that same Legacy in a
way that no one saw coming less than one
percent of North Koreans are allowed
access to the internet and there are
only 1 000 IP addresses in the whole
country so to train this new Army they
recruit students with promising math
skills and send them to countries like
China to train in computer science then
they assign them to work in hidden
locations in China to have full access
to the internet and go completely
undetected they're extremely skilled at
avoiding detection in other ways too
using dozens of names in order to
confuse law enforcement but we would
come to know them as Lazarus what's more
is that even if they do get caught North
Korea is completely cut off from the
rest of the world what are you gonna do
extradite them send in CIA agents to
catch these hackers anyone who does get
linked to Lazarus is completely
Untouchable all of this means that this
hacker Army has flown under the radar
for years and it wasn't until 2014 that
an attack happened big enough to catch
America's attention
[Music]
in 2014 Sony Pictures was making the
Masterpiece of a comedy that is the
interview if you haven't seen the movie
yet you definitely should but as you can
imagine the real Kim Jong-un was not a
big fan of this movie North Korea even
went on to call this masterpiece an act
of War but the way North Korea
retaliated caught everyone by surprise
just before Thanksgiving that Year
everyone at Sony came to work one
morning and discovered their security
badges weren't working when they tried
to log into their computers they were
greeted with a message warning them that
if they didn't comply with shutting down
that movie they would release Sony's top
secrets for the world to see and when
the company didn't comply the Lazarus
group released the data even emailing it
directly to news stations across the
country now this data held some juicy
details that Sony did not want the
public to know Secrets like executive of
salaries confidential internal emails
Insider gossip emails where producers
and Executives called Angelina jolia
spoiled brat or Kevin Hart there were
even racist comments made about Barack
Obama unfinished films and scripts were
leaked and thousands of people had their
identities and Social Security numbers
stolen but even after that leak Sony
went forward with production of the film
so the Lazarus group just doubled down
when the interview went to Premiere that
December the hackers threatened physical
violence comparing what would happen to
September 11th cast members and their
friends were too scared to even go to
the premiere and even though no attacks
happened the damage was done no movie
theater was willing to show the film and
its debut was canceled and when it was
over the attackers fried all of Sony's
hard drives and servers it cost Sony
over 15 million dollars to clean up that
mess with Untold Millions more in Lost
film sales afterwards investigators said
that quote the folks who did this didn't
just steal everything from the house
they burned the house down end quote but
as flashy as this retaliation hack was
it wasn't really a money maker for the
Lazarus group unlike their other hacks
they didn't benefit much from it other
than upping their notoriety
Korea is pretty poor and the supreme
leader has some expensive bills to pay
they had to come up with a money-making
hack fast and so their next mission
became a hundred million dollar Heist
[Music]
in February 2016 a Lazarus group
attacked the Swift system in the Central
Bank of Bangladesh
Swift is the system used to make
international money transfers
it's pretty much one of the only legal
ways to send money from one country to
another
and once they got into Bangladesh bank's
Network they made fake transactions to
the Federal Reserve in New York City 20
million dollars was sent to Sri Lanka
and another 80 million dollars to the
Philippines the money was hidden in
multiple unsuspecting accounts converted
to Philippine pesos and when they
finally got their hands on the money
they laundered it through casinos and
fake Charities they even timed it just
right so that Bangladesh had no chance
to warn anyone when they saw what was
going on the attack was made just at the
start of the Chinese New Year a
non-working holiday for all the
countries involved so by the time the
Philippines bank got the message it was
already way too late this attack made
North Korea the first and only country
to commit bank robbery over the internet
and while a 100 million dollar bank
robbery is already a big deal that is
chump change compared to the billion
dollars this Heist was supposed
deal they still got away with a fortune
and crippled the world's confidence in
the international banking system and
after this the Lazarus group was feeling
more powerful than ever so they decided
to launch another attack that would let
them just watch the world burn
[Music]
it was a Friday morning and NHS
healthcare workers across the UK were
going about their regular work shift
suddenly their computer screens started
going blank then displaying this message
it was a ransomware attack codenamed
wannacry the Lazarus group used
encryption software to scramble victims
files and the only way to unscramble
them would be for the hospital to pay up
but what freaked everyone out is that
unlike most attacks before which used
infected emails and spearfishing this
malware was spreading rapidly across the
internet all by itself
nobody had to click on anything to get
infected it happened all on its own it
paralyzed over a third of the UK's
hospitals and more than 600 private
practices across the country
CT scans and MRIs were down nobody could
see lab results or access patient
records doctors and hospitals were
forced to turn away all but the most
critical patients people would come in
with bone fractures be put in a splint
and be
while being told to come back in a few
days the situation quickly became a
national emergency but as more reports
kept flooding in people realized that
this attack wasn't just targeting the
NHS it wasn't affecting computers across
the planet it destroyed nearly 250 000
computers in over 150 countries doing
between 4 billion dollars to eight
billion dollars in damage in just one
afternoon
companies around the world were
paralyzed in a matter of hours it seemed
completely Unstoppable cyber security
firms around the world watched in horror
as nothing they tried seemed to work it
was the apocalyptic nightmare everyone
had been afraid of but that same day a
22 year old cyber security researcher
named Marcus Hutchins was helping to
investigate the attack when he noticed
the malware kept pinging an unregistered
web domain he paid the 10 bucks to
register it himself just to get a closer
look and then suddenly the attacks
stopped he'd found the malware's hidden
kill switch and turned it on just by
luck but sheer destruction and fear
spread by the attack wasn't even the
best part turns out wannacry's new
ability to hack computers remotely and
spread an infection all on its own was
thanks to a couple of leaked NSA Secrets
One was a weakness in just about any
computer that used Microsoft Windows and
the other was a special hacking tool
that the NSA had designed themselves
they had known about these weaknesses
for five years but kept them to
themselves
eventually these secrets were sold on
the black market and fell into North
Korea's hands
unlike the Bangladesh bank heist the
Lazarus group wasn't doing it for the
money this time since they charged 300
in Bitcoin per user and only made about
160 thousand dollars in total they just
wanted to see how much destruction they
could pull off in one shot but it
wouldn't be too much longer before they
turned back to stealing money and this
time they weren't going after regular
Banks
foreign
[Music]
as the Bangladesh bank robbery was North
Korea has found a much easier way to
steal money and get past those pesky
International sanctions cryptocurrency
all crypto values are given in USD value
at the time of the theft
on June 23rd of this year over 100
million dollars in crypto was stolen
from Horizon Bridge
once the money was stolen the Lazarus
group laundered it through crypto
laundering software called mixers but
you know what the craziest part is this
is one of the smaller heists they've
gotten away with
before hacking Horizon Bridge they
attacked the nft minting game axi
Infinity and the Lazarus group made off
with over 620 million dollars more than
600 million dollars from a single gaming
company and that's still not all back in
2019 the UN reported that North Korea
had already stolen more than two billion
dollars in crypto over the last decade
and just what are they doing with all
that money
foreign
Poverty of the country International
sanctions and the excess lifestyle of
the elite the country is bankrupt and
they have literally no way to make money
other than to steal it Kim Jong-un is
using these stolen funds to keep the
country running on the bare minimum to
keep to keep the Ordinary People subdued
and isolated and of course to build
Warheads capable of reaching New York
City
but as dramatic as he can be if Kim
jong-un's Army can find a way to attack
his enemies without starting nuclear
Armageddon they're going to find it
and one of America's biggest weaknesses
lies in how easy it could be to just
turn out the lights for good
with North Korea's reputation as poor
and isolated it's an easy mistake to not
take threats from them very seriously
but what people don't realize is just
how dangerous North Korea has made
themselves while the rest of the world
was asleep
now they can topple entire industries
from half a world away without ever
shooting a single bullet but it's like
one escaped member of North Korea's Army
says so well quote it is easy to wake up
a person who is sleeping but it's very
hard to wake up the man who is
pretending to sleep end quote it's easy
to ignore a problem by pretending it
doesn't exist
until the day comes when the lights go
North Korea's hacker Army may be
dangerous but it's nothing compared to
China's forced organ harvesting where
the Chinese military and hospitals
harvest the organs of prisoners while
they're still alive to sell to wealthy
westerners in dire need of an organ they
do this because it makes them a lot of
money we're talking 62 000 for a kidney
thirty thousand dollars for an eye a
hundred twenty thousand dollars for a
liver three hundred thousand dollars for
a pair of lungs however we have to stop
going over this right now before we get
demonetized and age restricted but if
you want to watch our full private
documentary on forced organ harvesting
and many other topics too controversial
for YouTube scroll down and click that
join button below this YouTube
membership came out of this need to
cover important topics that wouldn't fly
on YouTube it's where we post a new
private document every month never to be
released publicly and members love them
many say that this channel is the only
Channel they've ever clicked join on
because it's just that worth it and
there's a 30-day refund policy too
unlike most YouTube memberships meaning
if you join for the first time and you
don't think it's worth it email us and
we'll refund you your money so hit that
join button below to watch now
have you guys seen the interview movie
yet I personally really liked it even
though it was like fairly cheesy but
yeah if you're new here this is one of
the biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoyed this video click
that subscribe button below you can
follow me on Instagram jaketran but that
is going to wrap it up stay dangerous
out there and I will see you guys in the
next one
foreign
[Music]